[Musica]
buon salve è un periodo in cui mi sto
riguardando hunger games certo sto
guardando i giorni di nuovo per la
sedicesima volta e volevo fare un ultimo
episodio adesso che sono in tema su su
wang air games con i personalizzati
volevo fare l'ultimo episodio perché non
mi è mai andata giù il fatto che non ho
vinto questo sarà l'ultimo ma prego gesù
di riuscire a vincere almeno almeno una
volta almeno ora questa volta
diversamente dalle altre volte le
squadre sono fatte completamente a caso
distretto 1 più di fi e albano distretto
2 selena gomez arena grande distretto 3
fede s.pietro ristretto quattro tutor e
jacopo distretto 5 jason e capri ponte
distretto 6 mar come rino è il surreal
power che insieme c'azzecca non c'erano
la stessa barba modo molto simile
distretto 7 j ax e vegas miss 38 anima e
sabri che sono per culo finiti nello
stesso squadra distretto 9 stefani e
ciccio distretto 10 fa vj e daniel fi
che quei capelli spaventino tutti quanti
perché se non vinciamo la colpa è tua e
solo tu a style 11 giulia penna e martin
garris distretto 12 p.te katniss aver
loro due li ho lasciati così va bene
squadre a caso pro ceed ha ovviamente
mettiamo la classica traduzione perché
sennò mentre gli ostaggi stanno sui podi
suona il corno catrice trova capita si
nasconde nella cornucopia e lo uccide
ma la storia d'amore durata quattro
capitoli a che cosa strani chi è servita
a subito la coppia è possibile ma è ok
non è un problema finché sono vivo io no
problem la vj scappa dalla cornucopia
jacopo scende dalla cornucopia pietro e
gabry ponte combattono per una borsa che
aprì pontari numeri rinuncia ai ritiri
sa bene ciccio trova una borsa piena di
esplosivi è questa l'espressione che ha
usato quando l'ha trovata con contento
per miss kappa jason strappa una cagna
dalle mani di anima la scossa con una
canna saint jacques la stai facendo cioè
seppur di squadra cosa prese non ho
capito perché avevi
in una 2000 sasha perché sto scherzando
vi amerò ironico ironique fa vj giulia
penna mette fuori un esplosivo uccidendo
tutor povero tudor e tra l'altro da
sempre più forte questa volta è morto
subito bene allora per adesso giorno
ancora durante il giorno giulia penna a
ruba da vegas mentre non sta guardando
marco marino si fa camuffare nei
cespugli beh basta che dipingi la la
barba di verde non ti vedevi nessuno j
ax e albano tracciano ed uccidono anima
una coppia fantastici pietro e daniel si
sono separati per cercare risorse ma dio
mio
daniel mi ha già tradito con pietro ci
ha messo 0,2 secondi
jason esercita il suo tiro con l'arco
non so che cosa possa mai vedere dietro
con la maschera per selena traccia e
uccide sabri ok fa vj scopre una grotta
papà cosa mi serve una grotta ma scusami
ma fai qualcosa vide ci ammazza qualcuno
per adesso ragazzi sono morti pitt ha
subito tudor fedez anima e sapri quindi
per adesso
ok al bano cerca di cantare per dormire
ma dio mio albano tutte canti per
dormire non ti si può vedere alle ore
il mio lunghe
ricapito non puoi fa così per dormire
fra svegli tutti cioè tutti i più di
tutti svegli fa vj e martin garics
tengono le mani cosa è una roba tipo
heidi che camminiamo contenti di ciò che
da pietro a pietro di ucciderla
ovviamente ci c'è una donna rifiuta
mantenendo ciccio vivo merck marco
merlino urla per aiuto jacopo raccoglie
fiori ragazzi siamo veramente agli
sgoccioli una persona letale fa vj
chiude in silenzio il collo di ciccio
proprio io ho preso il collo e patisce
vegas decapita daniela madon decapita
daniel con una spada che però con quei
capelli secondo me ha fatto solo bene
gabry ponte devia l'attenzione di albano
e scappa ha fatto il remix di gabry di
albano al bagno tutto dal panic ato
marking alex regola marco merlino in
fiamme con una molotov gli ha preso
fuoco la barba non ha più spento niente
divampato un incendio proprio mediano
subito chi è morto allora ciccio che gli
ho fatto così daniel che aveva i capelli
brutti e marco merino che gli ha preso
fuoco la barba fantastico procedere
pietro il pd poi si scontrano decidono
di fermarsi per la notte
ok ragazzi siamo arrivati al momento
clou di questi hunger games prestate
attenzione al bano uccide fa vj con la
propria roma ma io dico un po di cantare
per dormire che era meglio addormenta
vita lo stavo scherzando prima top dormi
dormi maledizione ariana grande stacca
jason vuol dire che stacca a genova gli
ha staccato la testa
non capisco è possibile ascoltare un
cannone in distanza va
[Musica]
niente rai che non c'è verso porca vacca
incastrata dentro al bano procedere
dipendente di salire su un albero ma
cade su albano uccidendole entrambe the
perfetta il karma albano il karma su
realpower attacca katniss ma martin
garics la protegge uccidendo su
realpower ok pietro mette stern il fuoco
con una molotov
jason può gestire le circostanze
commette suicidio ci hai messo una vita
a netta passata da aver paura di sto
pirla e voi scommette suicidio è un
genio
selen ariana grande jacopo traccia ne
uccidono katniss ci sono voluti in tre
per uccidere che gli spessori vegas era
ora di leggere una cosa così temeraria
bravo vegas sono morti pd pie albano
surreal powers tecniche e morto ed è
sparita pure l'immagine jason kenney
saint martin garris procedere j ascia
jay asher j ax ha inconsapevolmente
mangia bacche tossica gabry ponte cade
in una fossa e muore
pietro mette in dubbio la sua sanità
abbiamo questo lo sapevamo già possono
essere ascoltati due cannoni in
lontananza gabry ponte j asha poverino j
ascia ora che vedete che i nuovi cd
nuovo pietro sempre pietro vice madonna
me ne vado ebbero giuro vegas uccide
jacopo con una falce attenzione giulia
bellarena grande pietro entro in una
lotta pietro li uccide trionfalmente
entrambi raga vegas contro pietro
gran finale io ho fatto due volte gli
hunger games 2 volte ha vinto più 2 2
volte ha vinto pietro se vince anche
stavolta porca di una vacca me ne vado
perché non è possibile procedere cioè vi
giuro non è non è possibile
pietro amore dalla sete
bolelli maledizione mari dopo david poi
c'è sempre pietro prega sempre dietro
vince come grazie ha ammazzato tutti a
un killer in credito è morto di set ma
alla fine ha vinto vegas
perché dietro è morto di sette ma che
vittoria è la cosa sa incendio di nuovo
pietro ragazzo spaventato la strada
impossibile vabbè che l'iter aia
facciamo l'ultima perché mica è
impossibile non vinco veramente dai
l'ultima questa è l'ultima degli hunger
games sul mio canale l'ultima prova
voglio fare perché mica l'ultima
speranza una possibilità su 24 dai
famigerata e maledizione pro ceed subito
convoglio subito jason uccide albano per
le sue forniture
va bene ed è morto solo al bano adesso
anima soffoca ariana grande dopo aver
intrapreso una lotta di pugno va bene
pietro cerca di lanciare pesci con un
tridente tipo baseball e lanci un pesce
quel clan col tridente difficile giulia
pena barchi garics daniele anima
tracciano uccidono vari j
niente porca vacca niente non c'è verso
di esistere il suo gioco non c'è verso
cioè non ho parole
selena cade in un lago ghiacciato e
affogherà perché questi spoiler di mega
fuga nonché affogherà mio dio cioè io mi
sorprendo sempre di come l'italiana in
questo sito sia macinato tipo il caffè
fedez e trasforma la trasforma
l'attenzione di anima e scappa che cosa
vuol dire vegas cerca di lanciare pesci
che un intelligente aveva una moda sta
qua da olimpiadi campione di lancio di
pesci col tridente morte fa vj e morta
selena va bene in paradiso stiamo
insieme e almeno una notizia positiva da
tutto questo j ax cattura gravi pro e
gabry ponte dalla guardia e lo uccide
pietro distruggere forniture di tudor
mentre toma povero to do arma dai sarti
capri fonte tudor poverini ragazzi ma
perché giulia penna cuoca il suo cibo
prima di mettere fuori il suo fuoco
non capisco neanche sotto sforzo sapri
spara un colpo di fulmine alla madonna
cosa sei un eroe di league of legends
farà un colpo di fulmine velenoso nel
collo di surreal power lentamente
uccidendo lo alza uno cioè tridenti ca
i pesci la traspare il minimarket mi
siede capita fedez con una spada ciccio
piange tranquillamente cosa vuol dire
piange tranquillamente più di pai muore
dall'ipotermia che venisse forze anima
per uccidere pietro sabri decidere di
bici da di uscite di uccido non so
leggere vabbè ma questi italiano è tutto
suo quindi ci sta che non sappia
leggerlo decide comunque morta sabrina è
morta sabrina vabbè vita cerca di salire
su un albero ma cade su giulia penna o
cile ball ed io capisco non capisco
maisto gioco stanno tutti a guardare in
alto gli altri che salgono sugli alberi
cena ci voleva un genio aver morì così è
morti più di file sabri pita e giulia
penna vabbè anima colpisce j ax nella
parte posteriore con un tridente c'ha
pure le scarpe chic oltre i denti alla
fine gli ha infilato nel deretano j ax
ok katniss e lancia una freccia su
jacopo ma perde uccide stern invece back
e ai venice cake che che usa la freccia
ci può stare
marco brino grida a dormire anche lui ma
da al bano canta per dormire marco
marino urla per dormire ragazzi comunque
io tifo per merino è che non se non si
fosse capito tifo per lui
jacopo cerca di salire su un albero ma
cade alla sua morte pietro non può
gestire le circostanze commette suicidi
attenzione che siamo rimasti in
pochissimi che triste sconfigge marco
merlino in una lotta no ma risparmi
nella sua vita meno male non è morto
katniss usa nima come uno scudo dai mood
di scimmia
apprezzo lo sforzo di tentare di
spiegare cosa è successo ma non ci siete
riusciti gesù muore da sanguinamenti
interni causati da una scimmia ma come
una scimmia a si vede che saluta i mood
di scimmie riempiono la le l'arena che
sono in multe di sci vegas e ferisce
marco marin e lo lascia per limiti di
scimmia essere ascoltati 5 canoni
distanza jacopo pietro anima jason e
marco merlino chi è che è rimasto che
telis prende vegas dalla guardia e lo
uccide
va bene la vincitrice
gli ultimi hunger games sul mio canale e
che disse che credo sia forse la più
giusta quindi
hunger games si è concluso nel migliore
dei modi credo con la mia morte
all'inizio da chi arrivò a metà gioco c
è incredibile ma vera ghazi questo era
l'ultimo episodio di hunger games spero
vi sia piaciuto come se vi è piaciuto
sul momento mi piace ricordatevi che
pescare qui anziché lanciare i pesci due
tridenti nuova sport vi voglio vedere
tutti così potremo iniziare a lanciare
il sushi con la forchetta all'inizio poi
pian piano ci evolviamo ma ranieri si
avvicina ragazzi quindi ci vediamo a non
possiamo vito da ragazzi
[Applauso]
[Musica]